Wait, hold on a second.
I have a tail?
Whoa!
And how many red dots
can you count?
Look close. It's episode 50
of IMG!
Static electricity and packaging peanuts are always fun
together,
so is the creation of atom,
even though cats and dogs can do it too.
Oh, and this giraffe is having a fun
time, because he's being
kissed by a giraffe.
Peek-a-boo.
The only thing more delicious than a hamburger
eye makeup are Vsauce nails.
And,
if you walk around with your lips
puckered, from certain perspectives this
will happen. And is this a guy with no neck
wearing a purple shirt or is it...
wait, what? Now, this picture exhibits a
similar illusion. Get it?
It's just like this girl with a hairy
arm that I showed in a previous IMG!
Now, speaking of hair, here are some
wonderfully rigid structures
drawn
with hair-thin thread.
Even Chewbacca
is hair. And here's a pretty scene that
from far away or with your eyes squinted
looks like a skull.
Aww, a cute duck.
Gosh, dang it.
Short of the Week illustrated something
interesting.
The top 10 grossing films over periods of
10 years.
Blue titles are original ideas,
gray represents adaptations and pink represents
sequels.
Now, watch what happened as time went on.
In 2011, there wasn't a single
original movie idea in the top 10.
Tetris tights.
Now, let's watch a bunch of dogs
wearing shoes.
Here's a transformer who becomes a Game Boy.
And if your chin folds,
combined with your forehead creases
you wind up like this.
Draw bridge? Okay, if you say so.
And if you want to see a visualization
of the last 100 years
of shark attacks,
the National Post has this mammoth,
showing where in the world and where on the
body people became victims.
On Facebook, Kess warned us about the very serious
issue of drowning. LOL. And Leonardo showed us crayons carved into Star Wars shapes.
But you won't get lost with this giant
comprehensive math
of the entire Star Wars galaxy.
If you'd rather map something
fewer light years across,
check out this site, where you can see a map of the
wind, its patterns, as it invisibly tangles itself
across the USA.
Geographies of the World's Knowledge is a free booklet
available as a PDF or an iPad book and it shows
the distribution of knowledge in the
Internet age. The size of each country
is relative to number of people in it
who have access to Internet.
Its redness
is equal to the percentage.
And this map
shows the distribution of heavy metal
bands from around the world.
Now look at this from a distance and you will see
yourself. With most Vsauce videos end it's
like the end of a schools zone,
but when IMG number 50 is over,
it's the end of a
cool zone.
So, kitty, turn off the lights, because
as always,
thanks for watching.